foreign
I love you but even one of the greatest
Star Wars properties of all time doesn't
get away with a 35 second logo reveal
without a sin how does the distribution
of face paint work here what's the point
of war paint if everyone isn't wearing
it children are not excused
first rule of raiding parties stay with
the raiding party forcing a guy to climb
this Tower every day and risk hearing
loss when the people of ferrics could
just automate this you want clinging
metal sounds and bells get a grandfather
clock we've had them in this galaxy
since 1680. you all have light speed get
on it I'm sorry but judging from these
people's lives and the fact that they
can't afford Bells I just cannot believe
they just hang their gloves out for
anyone to steal I can't trust Denise not
to steal my hard-boiled eggs out of the
fridge but they just leave their work
gloves out totally breaks my immersion
geez dude if you distrust your
girlfriend this much break up all this
suspicion and sneaking around after her
will be the death of you we all know the
role Tim is going to play in this little
triangle don't we is it a cliche is it a
Trope is it a commentary on couple
culture and the valorization of
relational jealousy I'm quite proud of
that last one but take your pick also
snitching for the Empire he should know
how this ends
no what was it ditches riches fishes
damn okay I may not remember the exact
phrase but I do remember it's not good I
was helping peglin
tripped on a cable lying to your mother
she's old Casa she's not stupid I kick
again speak now read it hey don't you
get snippy with B because you're upset
with Casa Metroid was simply clarifying
your prior and somewhat conflicting
command he's a pure soul and doesn't
deserve your impatience we will not
stand for bee abuse here I missed them
you killed a guy with a backward head
butt your main mistake was not waiting
for a stiff breeze to kill him instead
with how experienced dandorm dicks are
with criminal underworld how do they not
notice this stooge standing at the bar
rage drinking in their direction also
Tim is stalking so hard in this episode
it's like he's begging us to pull out a
Timmy how's the peeping and we wouldn't
dare give him the pleasure Timmy Timmy
Define your boss's order so that you can
continue probing into a matter in the
name of an inexplicable boner for
Imperial law Cyril's the poster child
for why you should never be an
overachiever in life do the minimum
amount of work required to skate by
especially if you're the TV sins
narrator wait who wrote that last part
eating blue Cheerios this late at night
the only people can get away with eating
cereal this late have amoral friends
that are balding or barge into their
apartment to steal food who is it our
ring doorbell is not a thing in the Star
Wars universe ferrics is stuck with 80s
style apartment intercoms what do you
think the casting call for Tim was
looking for a man mid to late 20s who's
able to convey solely through staring
that he regrets kicking your dog but is
fully prepared to take a dump on your
cat while you watch no sir privilege
stuff got the brief on the ride in oh
cool now there are two antagonists with
inexplicable boners for Imperial law
Cyril and Scottish Cyril so one suspect
how many men do you think we need
apparently no women shall be admitted
into the incel squad it's a plague on
discipline it's ironic you're talking
about discipline when you're both
disobeying direct orders to drop this
case and are about to rope 12 more men
into your insubordination and the best
way to keep the blade sharp is to
think the blade actually dulls it the
best way to keep a blade sharp is to
sharpen it I'm starting to suspect you
lack smithing skills Soldier then again
the only time we actually see physical
blades used in Star Wars is when they're
inexplicable plot devices for lackluster
conclusions to trilogies
along your kind words to the Chief
Inspector fascist meet cutes aren't they
adorable they look like they're about to
knock off early and go to a space book
burning together
the show has some amazing shots go ahead
take us in offer the Glorious space porn
damn Stellan Skarsgard looks awesome in
this coat none of my jackets are
anywhere near this cool reminding me
once again that I will never look as
cool as any of the skarsgards tell me
half you can't just say coffee I don't
think it ruins the world of Star Wars to
admit they have coffee like we do here
hell there's a whole Diner in episode
two you remember that yeah I try not to
either go the andors are so mean to be I
wish we had at least one scene of them
being decent to their buddy like Cal and
bd1 so here's two sins for not treating
this precious cinnamon roll with more
kindness Justice for B
the Lord of the qunari Flies you had
eight whole seconds of this guy standing
up and you didn't warn your leader
before she got shot there's like 20 kids
hiding back there now one of them
thought their leader needed a warning
about the armed man standing up behind
her sometimes the kid's sin just isn't
enough I count at least 12 darts in this
guy before he collapses hey I might want
to consider adding more Venom to your
darts if it takes that many and that
long to down someone you know anybody
from Canary of course he'd end up asking
this of Cassian yes in space no one can
hear you coincidence
spot it I'm saying this because this
somehow manages to come off more
well-natured than condescending which is
impressive but I don't want to like this
guy
I'm old enough I bet there isn't a
Galaxy where this is okay this is the
guy who takes the urinal right next to
you to chat it's just rude and you're
turning my shy bladder agoraphobic you
obnoxious P Crowder don't find it here
it's not worth finding who says that
exactly because ferrics looks like a
pretty sad place and I've driven through
Southern Arkansas I feel like they
didn't know how to end this episode so
they just decided to have Andor walk
toward the camera while badass music
plays damn it it works
oh
three torches too much
[Music]
more cereal that's your third bowl today
you had it for breakfast and lunch
when everyone I've told is dead it's a
weird Vlog spent before